his book the parades gone by is as find  a comprehensive history of the silent  era as you can probably find anywhere  his  monumental 13-hour documentary  hollywood the silent years  is thrilling in its scope  and we mustn't overlook  his important role in film preservation  and restoration  of course  there are many more books many more  documentaries such as the ones on buster  keaton  charlie chaplin harold lloyd  greta garbo mary pickford douglas  fairbanks  d.w griffith et cetera et cetera et  cetera i do go on but then so do kevin's  many accomplishments  therefore i'm now going to ask kevin  brown to please stand so that we may  suit him salute his achievements  in giving a voice  to the history of silent films kevin  brownlow  you